the post-processing step in a question
answering task
when doing question answering the
processing of the initial data set
implies splitting the examples in
several features which may or may not
contain the answer
passing both features through the model
will give us logits for the start and
end positions since our labels are the
indices of the tokens that correspond to
the start and end of the answer
we must bend some more converse with
logics into an answer and then pick one
of the various answers each feature
gives to be the answer for a given
example
for the processing step you should refer
to the video link below it's not very
different for validation we just need to
add a few lines to keep track of two
things
instead of discarding the offset
mappings we keep them and also including
them the information of where the
context is by setting the offsets of the
special tokens and the question to none
then we also keep track of the example
id for each feature to be able to map
back feature to the examples that we
originated from
if you don't want to compute the
validation loss you won't need to
include all the special code that we use
to create the labels
with this done we can apply that
preprocessing function using the map
method
we take the squared data set like in the
preprocessing for question and solving
video
once this is done the next step is to
create our model we use the default
model behind the question answering
pipeline here
but you should use any model you want to
evaluate
with the 2tf dataset method we can just
send our process data set to
model.predict
and we directly get our start on
netlogits for the world that are set as
numpy arrays
with this done we can really dive into
the post processing
first we'll need a map from example to
features which we can create like this
now for the main part of the post
processing let's see how to extract an
answer from the logits
we could just take the best index for
the start and unlock its and be done but
if our model predicts something
impossible like tokens in the questions
we'll look at more of the topics
note that in the question answering
pipeline we attributed the score to each
answer based on the probabilities which
we did not compute here
in terms of logits the multiplication we
had in this course becomes an addition
to go fast we don't look at all possible
start and end logics but the 20 best
ones
we ignore the logits but spawning's
possible answers or answers that are too
long
as we saw in the preprocessing the
levels 0 0 correspond to no answer
otherwise we use the offset to get the
answer inside the context
let's have a look at the predicted
answer for the first feature
which is the answer with the best score
or the best luggage score since the soft
market is an increasing function
so model got it right
next we just have to loop this for every
example picking for each the answer with
the best logic score in all the features
the example generated
now you know to get answers from your
model predictions